we do have ali reza in the house already
first of all this is fresh to you right
now tell us a bit about this end of this
wild game
yeah um
okay first of all i am very relieved
that he he didn't see the queen c6 did
you see it yeah i saw the move
immediately after i took on his wife
so you have a good poker face
that answer uh answers our question
because we were considering queen takes
e6 and obviously peter said that he
looked at you and you didn't
sure no it was very lucky because
normally you think about this kind of
moves um because he was struggling also
that was the point that maybe because he
was struggling you you see all the moves
you calculate all the moves so i was
very lucky here that he missed this
queen c6 so yeah this is did you show it
to him after a round i told him but okay
he was not also very upset because okay
it's just it's just my luck that he got
this chance so
absolutely and
did you get this i think how you were
winning after king to f5 yeah i saw the
commentary but uh
before that i think i should have played
maybe more uh accurately yes
way before um
i think
instead of g4 i said maybe c7 i have
some chances
um
c7 here yeah but it's wrong g38 g4
bishop to c8 seems to be one five yeah
some sort of a race
knight a6
f6 unlike c7 yeah
okay
yeah then g4 is logical so
before that i was losing yeah but then
yeah i got this chance to push my pawns
so but he reacted very accurately also
because it could get tricky for black
so well knight takes e6 right now is the
only move right yes
and he found it and then you guys yeah
it was lucky this presentation but did
you see the end of it after king to f5
the way to win this one after check e5
check check you go to h8 yeah this is
insane it's just wild stuff
i had the feeling that this should might
be winning but um i didn't have time to
think about it so
i was always worried that he could
put the queen on for instance he even
here it's by lock that is winning queen
g5
d8 takes the eight actually is the kind
of d8 is a draw so you have to go e7
first
take something
yet
[Laughter]
i will show this to my students already
this is uh your first time in st louis
how is the atmosphere in your camp and
how do you feel playing yeah i really
like the city um as i expected i think
the chess club is very nice
and i'm happy to be here for the first
time so
um as i said in the open ceremony is
kind of it was my dream from childhood
to play here so
now i'm very happy and i'm looking
forward to this tournament i started
well
my last game was not very precise but i
take it to two and a half out of threes
okay how do you assess your uh chances
obviously after day one is a bit early
but how do you assess your chances to
win the event yeah i think if i continue
playing like this um i have good chances
but there are little things that i
should improve but if i manage to
continue like
this way and i have good chances i think
to win the tournament do you feel like
you're in shape right now are you seeing
the things that you should be seeing
yeah i think
okay the last round maybe i was a bit
tired but the previous games it was very
fresh so i'm happy here already
congratulations we'll see you tomorrow
thank you
oh congratulations too yeah absolutely
well well i love that e7